foreign
[Music]
no one dislikes only three things and no
one enjoys Swedish Cuisine fellow
jageriak lets in for that yogsgoyabara
also all being Vector sexually biased
the stirring of this drink with his
finger is just one of the many
Replacements this show has employed just
to avoid giving Archer an Apple so we
know he's an [__] Mallory doesn't
have anything in her hands so how is
this PowerPoint presentation
presentationing also d-o-mcratic what in
the absolute [__] is being taped so
frequently that it warrants this tape
dispenser taking up the entire left side
of this desk and on second Barrel I come
out all John vui you're gonna need to be
more specific that could be anything
from doing unnecessary flips to doing
unnecessary face surgery oh no we won't
give our baby chocolate refusing to give
a baby the deliciousness that is
chocolate oh wait it really is bad for
them well then the creation of a
biological system that can't digest the
deliciousness that is chocolate right
after birth oh you were talking about my
gun cupping either of Lana's guns
without her explicit consent
making knowing things feel inappropriate
oh man it's like the tacosaurus
trichosaurus doesn't have hands but he's
got some big old Pinchers he'll pinch
you all right but unfortunately you'll
never be able to use a hammer and there
is something sad about that what does
that smell grav locks and failure
pairing any meal with failure oh on
God's green earth dressed you somehow
Archer's state of dress wasn't the first
thing Mama Dearest noticed a full five
seconds ago when she answered the door
Woodhouse is already up to tying
Archer's tie for him but in the previous
shot Archer's shirt was also not
buttoned all the way up so can Woodhouse
button a button without actually
buttoning a button because I don't think
he can take his mind off Lana's huge
Johnny benchy and fingers we'll come up
with the base bullying playering
referencing's Mallory putting your
cigarette out in what looks like a pile
of potatoes when we all know beans and
onions are much more effective at
extinguishing a flame what is that a
calcium supplement neglecting the more
important question of whether or not
it's carbonate or citrate and if you
don't think the distinction is important
you should ask yourself if if you want
gas because that's how you get gas I
call him Fister room butter but it
doesn't just fit
it will damn it Pam's ability to take
something that's funny on its own and
then send it into orbit is going to
knock us sin off the counter isn't it
except for the negrits being old-timey
offensive he is still offensive [__]
hipsters Destiny no she's not passable
with that Adam's Apple she looks like
she swallowed a Rubik's Cube Archer says
something offensive because he has no
filter and no real understanding of
right or wrong and the audience is
supposed to find it funny just because
it's a terrible thing to say cliche when
I served in the king's African rifles
the locals and busy tribesmen called
human flesh long Pig never much cared
for it being able to stomach eating
people but still letting Archer treat
you like dirt Woodhouse [__] bite his
ass help with what sir no I was
addressing you as hell addressing the
help is help do you want a chocolate pie
that includes an ingredient of feces
because this is how you get a chocolate
pie that includes an ingredient of feces
I wonder if Dr panty model knows how
many pounds of pressure it takes to snap
a human collarbone she probably uses the
metric system Cyril would be the number
one agent at TV since I find your lack
of faith disturbing I find your Manish
hands disturbing I find it unbelievable
that Lana walks around quoting Star Wars
but here we are and yes I'm not calling
it a New Hope or Star Wars episode four
it's [__] Star Wars and you [__]
know it I find your Manish hands
disturbing I think they're kind of sexy
their fingers Pam not kielbasa I'm
thinking kyrophilia and cytophilia can't
occupy the same space and time yes
measure I am in position and ready to
eliminate the Target first off the only
position you're in is the one of sitting
down in the bathroom variety and second
why are you taking any kind of chance on
someone outside the bathroom hearing
this conversation shouldn't you have
laid out all of these plans before
getting to Mallory's home
find it much harder to bribe a dead man
for the U.N contract
I will find it much more enjoyable to
work with the woman who runs Isis haha
fun joke Yakov but if you know that
Mallory is trying to get you in contract
how does killing utney prevent Odin from
getting the U.N contract serve your goal
of becoming her Inside Man sure creates
all the fun multiple assassins hijinks
that ensue but this story could use a
little Clarity on how all its spycraft
nonsense actually works why don't you
just score it on everybody why are you
just pouring it on anybody's what is
this Amateur hour at least make a
reduction a gravy or an aju I kept it on
the nightstand to wake Nanny whenever
Sterling wet the bed wait who's bed it
was always a don't ask don't tell why
would Cheryl even think to ask this
question Mallory statement was in no way
confusing in regards to this area they
were blanks only if the back of his
skull picked that exact moment to
explode outwards what
Valerie because torvald was shot in the
chest and fell back before he could have
been shot in his skull also Mallory with
all her time in the Spy game doesn't
recognize what bullets hitting a body
looks like I think you have some serious
and unresolved issues with your father
and maybe that is why I did a rake
these two need to go to couples
counseling so they can unpack this
relationship and stop asking us too now
drop your gun between the body no have
you ever seen CSI this is already like
clued out episode promises us to visit
to clue town but episode never delivers
on said visit to clue Town well this
tort's a winner Mallory what was that
name again Claude Kaka damn it Cyril
klakaka is much closer to a brownie or
chocolate lava cake than it is to a tort
also who got all the [__] blood out
of the carpet
oh
screaming crazy on shooting blanks I
think he's already being regaled why
must you micro manage everything he's a
fully integrated multi-fedish artificial
being I also promised you a baby how's
that working out for you release him I
don't know I think there's like a racial
component don't worry this is a normal
smell well it depends on your first Dosa
just strange to hear it out loud think
of it as a team building exercise Odin
can suck it
yeah
wow this tastes weird for six years
running the contract has gone to Odin I
am
the first we make a big phony attempt to
kill torvalde okay and the second well
so three of
them what does that smell I could have
been at a barbecue you haven't even
tried the fish ball saggy bottom balls
is what you called me when I served in
the king's African rifles the knuckles
and busy tribesmen called human flesh
long Pig
tastes like paint I find your lack of
faith disturbing my sense a distressing
lack of enthusiasm on your parts your
only condition is that you are a stupid
crazy girl you're a shitty old man with
a tiniest penis